>> Tucker: WELCOME TO "TUCKER
CARLSON TONIGHT."
HAPPY MONDAY.
NO SANE AMERICAN APPROVES OF
WHAT RUSSIAN HAS DONE IN
UKRAINE.
WE DON'T.
ON TWITTER YOU SEE DEMOCRATS
PRETENDINGING THEIR POLITICAL
OPPONENTS SUPPORT THIS INVASION.
JOE BIDEN AND HIS STAFF SO
MISMANAGED THE WORLD THAT
VLADIMIR PUTIN INVADES UKRAINE
BUT ALL OF THIS IS YOUR FAULT.
THAT'S A LIE.
IN THIS COUNTRY EVERYONE
UNDERSTANDS THAT THE INVASION OF
UKRAINE IS BAD FOR US AND THE
WORLD AND VLADIMIR PUTIN IS BAD
TOO.
THOSE ARE SETTLED FACTS.
YOU CAN STOP DEBATING THEM.
THE QUESTION IS WHAT DO WE DO
NEXT?
VLADIMIR PUTIN'S BADNESS DOESN'T
ABSOLVE US OF OUR RESPONSIBILITY
TO THINK ABOUT HOW TO PROTECT
THIS COUNTRY AND THE REST OF THE
FREE WORLD.
PUTIN'S BADNESS MAKES WISE
DECISION MAKING IN THE UNITED
STATES MORE IMPORTANT THAN EVER.
IT'S NOT EASY TO SEE A LONGVIEW
WHEN YOU ARE ANGRY.
TANNER GREEN WROTE A PIECE
CALLED PAUSING AT THE PRECIPICE.
AMERICANS ARE OUTRAGED.
BUT OUTRAGE IS NOT ENOUGH.
IT'S NOT A FOREIGN POLICY.
HE WRITES MORAL OUTRAGE CAN BE
COUNTER-PRODUCTIVE.
"A RIGHTEOUS REACTION MAY BE
A DANGEROUS ONE.
IT'S OUTCOMES AND NOT INTENTIONS
THAT MATTER MOST.
FAILURES TO EXAMINE THE
MOTIVATIONS BEHIND OUR CHOICES
MAY LEAD TO DECISIONS THAT FEEL
RIGHT BUT FAIL TO REDUCE THE
HUMAN TOLL OF WAR IN THE LONG
RUN.
."
OUR LEADERS COULD TURN THIS INTO
A HISTORIC DISASTER.
THEY HAVE DONE IT BEFORE.
THE TWO MAIN THINGS TO WORRY
ABOUT.
FIRST, THIS WAR COULD GET MUCH
WORSE.
WE COULD SEE MANY AMERICANS DIE.
JOE BIDEN IS TELLING US WE WON'T
COMMIT AMERICAN TROOPS TO
UKRAINE AND CLAIMS HE OPPOSED
THE VACCINE MANDATE.
IS HE TELLING THE TRUTH?
EVEN IF HE IS IN THIS CASE,
BIDEN CAN'T SEE THE FUTURE.
HE HAS NO IDEA WHAT WILL HAPPEN
TOMORROW OR NEXT WEEK OR NEXT
YEAR.
NOBODY DOES.
MANY IN IT WASHINGTON ARE
PUSHING FOR A HOT WAR WITH
NUCLEAR ARMS WITH RUSSIA AND
A NO PLACE SO AMERICAN FORCES
WOULD SHOOT DOWN RUSSIA JETS.
THE UKRAINIAN PRESIDENT
VOLODYMYR ZELENSKY IS ON BOARD
WITH IT THIS.
MANY IN CONGRESS REPORT TOO.
>> WE NEED TO AT THE INVITATION
OF UKRAINE, DECLARE UKRAINE
A NO-FLY ZONE ENFORCED BY NATO
AND THE UNITED STATES.
THE AIR SPACE IS STILL CONTESTED
BY THE UKRAINIANS.
WE COULD SHUT DOWN RUSSIA AIR
OPERATIONS EVEN IF WE DON'T
ENGAGE RUSSIA TROOPS ON THE
GROUND.
>> Tucker: THAT'S A LIE.
IT'S HARD TO OVERSTATE HOW
DISHONEST THAT CLAIM IS.
SHOOTING DOWN RUSSIAN PLANES
WILL MEAN ENGAGING RUSSIAN
TROOPS.
IF VLADIMIR PUTIN IS CRAZY THAT
COULD SPIRAL INTO NUCLEAR
CONFLICT.
YOU WOULD ONLY SUGGEST THAT IF
YOU HAVE NOTHING IT LOSE.
AND HE DOESN'T BUT MANY OF US
HAVE A LOT TO LOSE.
WE HAVE CHILDREN.
WE SHOULD PAUSE BEFORE WE DO
THAT.
ADAM THINKS YOU ARE A TRAITOR IF
YOU WORRY ABOUT WHERE THIS MIGHT
GO.
NOTHING BAD WILL HAPPEN.
MAYBE NOTHING BAD WILL HAPPEN,
BUT SOMETHING VERY BAD COULD
HAPPEN FAST.
ADULTS KNOW THAT.
WATCH ANY WAR IN HISTORY.
AMAZEINGLY SOME OF THOSE ADULTS
FAVOR THIS ANYWAY.
TWO FORMER COMMANDERS IN NATO
ARE PUSHING FOR ARMED
CONFRONTATION WITH THE RUSSIAN
MILITARY.
BREEDLOVE ACKNOWLEDGED THAT
A NO-FLY ZONE WOULD AMOUNT TO AN
ACT OF WAR.
BLEEDLOVE SAID HE IS FOR IT
ANYWAY.
OKAY.
THIS IS THE MOMENT WHEN
A FUNCTIONS NEWS MEDIA WOULD ASK
WHAT HAPPENS NEXT?
WHAT DOES THAT MEAN?
HOW FAR IS THE UNITED STATES AND
ITS POPULATION WHO WOULD FIGHT
THAT WAR PREPARED TO TAKE THIS
CONFLICT AND TO WHAT END?
ONCE WE STOP BOMBING RUSSIA WILL
PUTIN STOP BOMBING UKRAINE?
WHAT WILL BE LEFT OF UKRAINE?
HOW ARE WE SURE PUTIN WON'T GO
NUCLEAR?
AND THEN, WHAT WILL CHINA'S ROLE
IN THIS WAR BE?
THANKS TO THE EFFORT OF THE
BIDEN ADMINISTRATION CHINA IS
VLADIMIR PUTIN'S STRONGEST ALLY.
CHINA SIGNED A LONG-TERM DID
ENERGY DEAL WITH RUSSIA.
THEY HAVE SKIN IN THE GAME AM
HOW SURE ARE WE THAT THE CHINESE
WILL STAY OUT OF A WAR?
HOW DO WE KNOW THEY WON'T TAKE
DOWN TO OUR DIGITAL
INFRASTRUCTURE WHICH THEY
CONTROL IN THIS COUNTRY.
REPORTERS ARE NOT ASKING THAT.
ASKING QUESTIONS IS IMMORAL.
RICHARD IS DEMANDING THAT
AMERICAN TROOPS FIGHT THE
RUSSIAN ARMY.
A MASSIVE RUSSIAN CONVOY IS 30
MILES FROM KYIV.
DOES THE WEST WATCH IN SILENCE
AS IT ROLLS?"
THE ANSWER IS WE CAN'T WATCH IN
SILENCE.
THIS IS MORAL BLACKMAIL.
NO ONE IN AMERICA FEELS ANYTHING
BUT REVULSEON AT THE SIGHT OF
RUSSIA IN UKRAINE.
HOW DO WE RESPOND?
THOUGHTFULLY IS THE ANSWER.
RICHARD HOSS THE PRESIDENT OF
THE COUNCIL ON FOREIGN RELATIONS
IS THE MAN YOU WOULD GO TO.
THAT'S HIS JOB.
WHATEVER YOU THINK OF THAT
COUNCIL, THEY ARE NOT A RADICAL
ORGANIZATION.
THEIR JOB IS TO LOOK AT THE
CONSEQUENCES OF ACTIONS.
BUT NOT MIM.
-- ANYMORE.
RICHARD HOSS IS IN FAVOR FOR
A HOT WAR WITH RUSSIA AND
CALLING A REGIME CHANGE.
WHAT COULD GO WRONG?
>> WE NEED TO RESPOND TO HIS WAR
OF CHOICE.
RAISE THE ECONOMIC COSTS AT HOME
AND THE MILITARY COSTS ON THE
GROUND.
I HATE BE TO SO BLUNT.
THE MOST VULNERABLE THING PUTIN
IS VULNERABLE TO IS DEAD RUSSIA
SOLDIERS.
MAKE SURE UKRAINE HAS THE MEANS
TO RESIST.
>> Tucker: HIS JOB IS A CABLE
NEWS PUNDIT.
THAT'S THE PROBLEM OF THE LEVEL
OF DISCOURSE AROUND THIS WAR.
WHEN REAL PEOPLE WITH JOBS THAT
HAVE ACTUAL AUTHORITY TALK ABOUT
CABLE NEWS PEOPLE THINGS CAN GO
SIDE WAYS.
IT WAS NOT IN DEFENSE OF
VLADIMIR PUTIN TO POINT OUT
A SHOOTING WAR WITH RUSSIA COULD
HAVE MASSIVE CONSEQUENCES FOR
US.
IT'S NOT JUST RUSSIAN SOLDIERS
WHO WOULD DIE.
MANY AMERICANS WOULD DIE.
IT'S NOT CERTAIN WE WOULD WIN
THAT WAR.
SORRY.
ASK ANYONE FAMILIAR WITH THE
CURRENT STATE OF READINESS OF
THE U.S. MILITARY?
IS VICTORY A CONCLUSION?
NO.
THIS IS NOT SADDAM HUSSEIN WE
ARE TALKING ABOUT.
ARE WE READY FOR ALL OF THIS?
WE ARE MOVING DOWN A PATH THAT
COULD RESULT IN THE DESTRUCTION
OF THE UNITED STATES.
AMERICANS MAY BE MAD AT PUTIN,
BUT THEY ARE WARY OF WHERE OUR
LEADERS ARE TAKING US NEXT.
A NEW CNN POLL SHOWS THE
MAJORITY OF AMERICANS OPPOSE
AMERICA GETTING INVOLVED.
WE COULD USE A SOBER NATIONAL
COVERINGS ABOUT THE POTENTIAL
CONSEQUENCES OF WHERE PEOPLE
LIKE RICHARD ARE TAKING US NOW.
INSTEAD WE ARE GETTING BAFFOON
LIKE KINSINGER.
HE POSTED IMAGES OF TWITTER
ABOUT SOMETHING CALLED THE GHOST
OF KYIV.
IT WAS A HOAX BUT HE HAD NO IDEA
BECAUSE HE KNOWS NOTHING.
A SITTING MEMBER OF CONGRESS
TWEETING ABOUT A WAR LIKE IT'S
A CABLE NEWS SHOW.
WE OWN THE RUSSIAN AIRPORTS?
REALLY.
GET SOME RESPECT.
HE ATTACHED A PHOTO SHOP IMAGE
OF A COMEDIAN AS THE PILOT.
LET'S PAUSE AND THINK THIS TRUE.
THAT SEEMS FAIR.
AS WE DO THAT IT'S WORTH
CONSIDERING WHAT IS HAPPENING
HERE IN THE UNITED STATES
CONCURRENT WITH THE WAR AND
JUSTIFIED BY THIS WAR.
WE ARE SPEAKING OF OF THE
ASSAULT ON CIVIL RIGHTS
UNDERWAY.
IT IT WOULD BE IRONIC IF
A DEFENSIVE DEMOCRACY ON THE
OTHER SIDE OF THE WORLD LED TO
AN EROSION OF DEMOCRACY HERE.
THAT'S WHERE WE ARE HEADED.
THE MOMENT RUSSIAN TROOPS ROLLED
ACROSS THE BORDER INTO UKRAINE
DEMOCRATS WASTED NO TIME IN
ATTACKING NOT JUST PUTIN BUT
THEIR POLITICAL OPPONENTS IN
THIS COUNTRY.
WHAT DID THEY HAVE TO DO WITH
THIS?
WE ARE ALL IN THIS TOGETHER BUT
THEY LEVERAGED IT WAR AS HUMAN
SUFFERING TO MAKE PARTISAN
POINTS.
ONE MSNBC REGULAR SAID THE WHOLE
CONFLICT WAS THE RESULT OF
A PLOT INJURED BY VLADIMIR
PUTIN'S MOLE THE FORMER
PRESIDENT OF THE UNITED STATES.
>> TRUMP WEAKENED THE ALLIANCES
TO PREVENT PUTIN FROM ACHIEVING
HIS GOALS LIKE NATO AND OUR
RELATIONSHIP WITH OUR EUROPEAN
PARTNERS.
TRUMP WAS PUT IN AS A BULLDOZER.
>> Tucker: WE SPENT 3 YEARS
HOLDING THE LUNACY OF THE
RUSSIA-GATE PEOPLE AND LYING AS
EVIDENCE MAYBE THEY SHOULD NOT
HAVE AN EFFECT ON THE
CONVERSATION ABOUT POLITICS.
SOMEHOW THOSE VERY SAME
UNBALANCED PEOPLE ARE HAVING AN
EFFECT ON OUR FOREIGN POLICY.
TRY TO FOLLOW THE LOGIC HERE.
DONALD TRUMP TELLS EUROPE NOT TO
BECOME DEPENDENT ON RUSSIA OIL
WHICH HE DOES.
FOR IS REASON PUTIN WAITS TO
INVADE UKRAINE UNTIL HIS MAN IN
THE WHITE HOUSE IS GONE AND
PLAYING GOLF IN FLORIDA AND NOW
IT'S DONALD TRUMP'S FAULT THAT
EUROPE IS DEPENDENT ON RUSSIA
FOR ENERGY.
YOU CAN IMAGINE MSNBC VIEWERS
NODDING ALONG.
YES, THIS MAKES SENSE.
WHAT IS SCARY IT'S NOT CONFINED
TO MSNBC.
THE OVERLAP BETWEEN MSNBC GUESTS
SHOUTING NONSENSICAL PARTISAN
TALKING POINTS AND DEMOCRATIC
POLICY MAKERS IS PROFOUND SAYING
PEOPLE IN THE UNITED STATES ARE
WORKING FOR VLADIMIR PUTIN.
ERIC STALWELL TOOK THE MAXIUM
CAMPAIGN DONATION FROM THE
LOBBIEST FOR NORD STREAM-2 WHICH
WILL GIVE RUSSIA GREATER CONTROL
OVER THE ENERGY GRID AND FROM
WHICH THE RUSSIAN GOVERNMENT
PROFITS.
ERIC STALWELL IS TAKING MONEY
FROM THE RUSSIAN.
HE HAD SEX WITH A CHINESE SPY?
WITH A RUSSIAN SPY?
WE DON'T KNOW.
THE ONE GUY THAT SHOULD NOT BE
CALLING ANYONE TRAITORS IS
ACCUSING OF ANYONE ELSE ROOTING
FOR RUSSIA.
>> WE HAVE REPUBLICANS ROOTING
DONALD TRUMP, AND MIKE POMPEO
AND TUCKER CARLSON ARE ROOTING
FOR RUSSIANS.
THAT'S REPLAYED ON RUSSIAN TV TO
RALLY RUSSIANS.
>> Tucker: THAT'S AN AWFUL THING
TO PLAY.
WE HESITATEED TO PLAY THAT.
IT'S AN EFFORT TO COVER THEIR
OWN TAX.
IN ANCIENT HISTORY A WEEK AGO
THEY TOLD US THAT SANCTIONS
WOULD PREVENT A RUSSIA INVASION.
THEY WERE WRONG ABOUT THAT.
IF THERE WAS A SINGLE AMERICAN
WHO DESERVES SCORN AND BLAME FOR
THE INVASION OF UKRAINE IT'S JOE
BIDEN.
IT WAS HIS JOB TO PREVENT IT.
THEY WON'T ADMIT THAT.
THEY ARE ATTACKING YOU WITH
PARTISAN GOALS IN MIND.
DEMOCRATS PLAN TO USE THE
UKRAINE INVASION IN THE VERY
SAME WAY THEY USED JANUARY 6TH.
THAT EVEN STRENGTH TAKES PLACE.
NO ONE IS FOR IT.
NO ONE DEFENDED THE RIOT ON
JANUARY 6TH.
WE CERTAINLY DIDN'T.
HISTORY IS WRITTEN IMMEDIATELY
FOR PARTISAN MOTIVES.
YOU TAKE THE HYSTERIA OVER THAT
EVENT AND YOU USE THAT TO PURGE
THE COUNTRY OF THE DEMOCRATIC
PARTIES POLITICAL OPPONENTS.
THEY HATE POPULACE POLITICS MORE
THAN THEY HATE VLADIMIR PUTIN.
THEY ARE USING THIS OPPORTUNITY,
THIS WAR IN EASTERN EUROPE TO
SHUT DOWN DISSENT IN THE UNITED
STATES.
YOU ARE SEEING IN THE ALLIES
FIRST.
SEVERAL INCLUDING CANADA BAND
JOURNALISTS WHO DON'T AGREE WITH
THEIR VIEW OF THE WAR.
IF WE ARE GOING TO PROTECT
DEMOCRACY THAT SHOULD START AT
HOME.
DEMOCRACY IS DEFINED BY THE
TOLERANCE OF THE REGIME FOR
DISSENT.
NO DISSENT IS ALLOWED.
THEY PULLED US FROM THE AIR
WAVES IN CANADA.
THAT LED TO THIS QUOTE:
WILL BIDEN CRACKDOWN ON RUSSIAN
DISINFORMATION AND TUCKER
CARLSON WHO PROMOTES RUSSIAN
TALKING POINTS.
THEY ARE USING THIS TO SHUT DOWN
ANY JOURNALIST WHO QUESTIONS THE
DEMOCRATIC PARTY.
HOW DID WE GET HERE?
HOW CORRODED HAVE THESE PEOPLE
BECOME?
THEY ARE CALLING FOR GOVERNMENT
CENSORSHIP OF DISSENT AND
TELLING US THEY ARE DEFENSE
DEMOCRACY.
HERE'S NANCY PELOSI.
>> WE TALKED ABOUT THE FACT THE
ASSAULT ON UKRAINE WAS AN
ASSAULT ON DEMOCRACY.
BARBARA TALKED ABOUT THE ASSAULT
ON OUR DEMOCRACY IN OUR OWN
COUNTRY.
>> THE FIGHT FOR DEMOCRACY IS
TAKING PLACE AROUND THE WORLD.
IT'S NOT ONLY IN UKRAINE.
IT'S IN OUR OWN COUNTRY.
THROUGH THE CAMPAIGNS OF
MISINFORMATION AND
DISINFORMATION WE SEE THIS
HAPPENING THIS UKRAINE.
NOW WE SEE THEM TRYING TO TAKE
AWAY THE VOTING RIGHTS OF PEOPLE
OF COLOR, AFRICAN-AMERICANS AND
YOUNG PEOPLE AND THE SENIORS AND
THE DISABLED.
>> Tucker: YOU CAN ONLY FEEL
DEEP SADNESS THAT THEY REPRESENT
YOU IN OUR LEGISLATURE.
AS LONG AS WE ARE PUNISHING
PEOPLE WHO ARE ALIVE.
CHINA IS NOW RUSSIA'S STRONGEST
ALLY IN THE WAR.
THAT HAS IMPLICATIONS FOR NANCY
PELOSI WHOSE FAMILY GOT RICH
FROM CHINA.
YOU SHOULD BE VERY AWARE THAT
THERE ARE PARTISAN FORCES USING
THE WAR IN UKRAINE TO ACCOMPLISH
POLITICAL OBJECTIVES HERE AND
GAIN MORE POWER FOR THEM.
IT IS NOT ABOUT SHUTTING DOWN
FOX NEWS.
IT'S ABOUT SHUTTING YOU UP.
IF YOU DOUBT THAT, YOU SHOULD
KNOW THAT SENATOR MARK WARNER OF
VIRGINIA WROTE A LETTER TO HIS
DONORS IN TECH DEMANDING THEY
RESTRICT THE SPREAD OF RUSSIAN
PROPAGANDA.
WE ARE SENSITIVE ON THE TOPIC
AND YOU SHOULD BE TOO.
WARREN REPORTED THAT HIS DONORS
IN BIG TECH COMPLIED WITH HIS
DEMANDS.
>> YOU SENT LETTERS TO THE
LEADING SOCIAL MEDIA COMPANIES,
META, WHICH RUNS FACEBOOK,
ASKING THEM TO PREVENT RUSSIA
PROPAGANDA OPERATIONS FROM
APPEAR ON THEIR PLATFORMS.
YOU HAVE RECEIVED ANY RESPONSES
YET THAT THEY TAKE THAT ACTION?
>> WELL, DAVID, THE SHORT ANSWER
IS YES.
EVERY ONE OF THESE PLATFORMS HAS
TAKEN DOWN SOME OF THE RUSSIAN
ACTIVITY AND THEY ARE NOT MAKING
MONEY OFF RUSSIAN ADS.
THAT'S GOOD AM I COMMEND THESE
PLATFORMS.
>> Tucker: CONTRAST WITH THE
CLIP FROM MSNBC WE JUST PLAYED.
DUMB PEOPLE DOING PROPAGANDA AND
TELLING YOU RUSSIA INVADING
UKRAINE IS ABOUT RACISM IN THE
SOUTH.
YOU WILL NOTICE THAT THE CIA
SHIELD SAID RUSSIAN STATE MEDIA
OR RUSSIA PROPAGANDA.
HE IS NOT TALKING ABOUT BANNING
RUSSIAN STATE MEDIA.
HE IS TALKING ABOUT BANNING
RUSSIAN PROPAGANDA A TERM HE
GETS TO DEFINE AND CENSORING THE
OPINIONS OF AMERICANS.
THAT'S NOT ALLOWED IN
A DEMOCRACY.
IN A DEMOCRACY, CITIZENS WHO
RULE HAVE A RIGHT TO HAVE ANY
OPINIONS THEY WANT, PERIOD.
THAT'S NOT AN ANCILLARY FREEDOM.
FREEDOM OF SPEECH IS THE CENTRAL
FREEDOM WE HAVE.
IT'S THE WHOLE POINT THE
COUNTRY.
THERE IS NO POINT IN SUPPORTING
UKRAINE IF OUR LEADERS IGNORE
OUR OWN BILL OF RIGHTS.
WE SHOULD DEMAND THE